yeah hello I'd want to see your plane
fuga from belgium hoping for some
transposition it will see for into my
lying down at that play doesn't happen I
think this is actually not that great
because of c3 and before it and it is
played ok let's try cooker ok but this
should be six is coming very not it it's
not easily possible for me to prevent it
yeah well this should be six games a
temper at least okay good I don't know
if he falls any good but counseling
cannot be wrong okay so quite happy with
the bishop alien what's the prayer
what's the plan though he cannot go
before I can take it I would like to go
if I've to be 4i and myself rook e8
Bishop back and deform would be a plan
okay a five this removes b5 that could
be his idea okay i think i'll stop a 50
night I'm taking that's a great
structure now the Queen side is
completely completely am completely wind
for white
I wonder 935 yak of course in foil see
that Bishop has to be made in mol biol
yes f3 stuff I'm still reasonably happy
with this I maybe should have played
different players l96 takes takes f3 i
would like to be ready for that okay and
then it gets the default gazook t7 and
at once that was very unnecessary to
allow
look da through c7 now this is actually
what I should do I mean the c7 point is
not that important if he really decides
to take it I mean look at snow square so
yep he decided not to yeah so that was
quite unnecessary to allow him all that
good thinking aid but he will miss that
traffic
okay let's see do I just take it on ya
again the position is very close though
you still have to convert let's stop any
d6 and then roop t6g 5 is the plan g5
okay so this is closed preparing a form
king will go to the six and then f4
we needs to do something for at four is
the thing
nice basic respect that cannot be cannot
do much yet to defend it's a completely
passive position play ignite yeah i
overlooking Ada and I really did it did
a bad job here I think around here and
black solution must be pretty
comfortable with the with the bad porn
structure like here this is really nice
but I didn't play this right yeah maybe
this is already unnecessary but I hear
ya here I was very sloppy and yeah this
is this is wrong so play okay this is
just not paying attention he will take
on c5 and I should be ready for that now
that was annoying but the good thing is
i can really give up the c7 pawn and I
should I think he can take it I don't I
don't think I can can trap the trappers
loop but I have to do it because
otherwise she gets the the default the
move suggested by the engine 96 is of
course also looking quite good giving it
up like that yeah I think I think this
is equal 0 books its own I didn't see
that I only saw this well I actually
thought that this game done that much of
a deal why should I be worth here well
I'm stuck mm I'm kind of tied to the
bottom that's true so Luke c7 which
basically forces this thing okay yeah
now that's true that's true i actually
forgot that i'm always tied to the b6
born
we never doubt Queen sir I'm okay but
with green school I had all the huge
opportunities and i'm already fine then
one no I'm more than fine yeah it was a
bit of a bit of a lucky win okay thanks
for watching